great series this year we're really
excited to start off customary law giver
factors at rpi and her PhD at MIT got
the key to Yale and 2009 professor of
geology business people seismologist I
am seismology outside Kamala's and
appropriately I hope you stay remember
if you if you register your registration
of the rapid karma propria
okay so without further ado join me
welcoming professional law can everyone
hear me is this downed okay all right
fantastic i can speak up if i exceeded
okay all right so is the mic on no okay
the i mean at the physical switch on
them on my mic is on but i don't know if
there's a setting but at in the meantime
i'm just going to start talking loud and
say hello and welcome and i'm really
glad that you're here i'm very excited
to have an opportunity to talk to you
today about earthquakes and volcanoes
and tsunamis oh my so as Kurt said I am
a seismologist so I'm a scientist who
studies earthquakes and I study the
structure of the deep earth using
earthquakes and one of the classes that
I teach here at Yale is called natural
disasters so I teach a whole semester
long class on some of the material i'm
going to talk about in my talk today oh
that sounded good that sound good I
could stand over here all right perfect
okay so a little bit about me so so
curtains introduction told you a little
bit about sort of where I went to school
I'm originally from Massachusetts so I
am a message our new england native
Massachusetts native i went to
Chelmsford High School in chelmsford
Massachusetts and then went off to
college and lived in a few different
places while I was getting my education
and then moved to Connecticut in 2009 so
I've been here for almost almost eight
years so one of the things that Kurt
asked me to talk to you a little bit
about before I start talking about
earthquakes and natural disasters is how
I became a scientist and for me the
story of how I became a scientist starts
with this map okay and this is actually
this map is also a really good
introduction to my talk so when I was in
eighth grade I took earth science that
was the science that everybody that
everybody maybe an everybody in
Massachusetts Public Schools took earth
science in eighth grade and a couple of
months into the school year we did an
activity on
plate tectonics where we had a map and
we filled out on the map the locations
of earthquakes and volcanoes and and it
showed that all of the earth year many
of the earthquakes and volcanoes
happened on the boundaries of tectonic
plates so I saw a map like this that
illustrates plate tectonics and I said
that is the coolest thing I have ever
heard of in my life that is what I want
to be when I grow up I think I was in
eighth grade so I was you know maybe
only a little older than some of you
guys are the same age as some of you
guys and so I said when I grow up I am
going to become a geophysicist and I am
going to study plate tectonics and then
Here I am so that's a that's really cool
so my eighth grade earth science class
got me into being a scientist and in
particular got me into this wanting to
study the earth it's an amazingly cool
place plate tectonics I'm going to tell
you a little bit about the theory of
plate tectonics in this talk it's an
amazingly cool scientific theory and it
lets us predict a lot about what we
expect with earthquakes and volcanoes
and tsunamis and natural disasters and
so that's what I'm going to talk to you
about today so usually when I give a
talk like this I like to start with a
natural disaster an earthquake or
volcanic eruption that was in the news
recently and unfortunately i usually
don't have to search very far to find
one because geologic disasters
unfortunately are pretty common so this
is a this is a picture from the
magnitude 6.2 earthquake that happened
last month in Italy who heard about this
on the news yeah almost everybody it was
a pretty important event in a really
devastating event so this was a
magnitude 6.2 earthquake in the apennine
mountains in italy it happened very
shallow which means that the earthquake
waves were happening sort of right
underneath places where people lived and
very tragically there were three hundred
casualties associated with this event so
all the time in the news were reminded
that we need to be aware of geologic
disasters and we need to do what we can
to work to mitigate the damage so this
earthquake was felt very widely in Italy
this is just a map the star is showing
the epicenter of the earthquake it was
felt over a very wide area from
basically from Naples up to Bologna so a
very
area of the country this is what we call
a shake map so this is a map that shows
the colors here illustrate how violent
the shaking was at different places and
you can see that it right near the
earthquake epicenter there was red red
colors so violent shaking so about as
violent as the shaking from an
earthquake gets earthquakes are quite
common in Italy this is that just a map
of Italy showing the historical
earthquake catalog and in particular
over the last 20 years or so there have
been three quite devastating earthquakes
right in that region of central Italy
where the earthquake last month happened
so Italy is a place that has to be very
aware of earthquake disasters so
oftentimes when I tell people that I'm a
seismologist they'll say hey I heard
about you know a couple of earthquakes
in the news last month it seems like
we've been having a lot of earthquakes
lately you know what's going on is this
unusual should do I need to panic and
the answer really is no even though you
know a big earthquake makes the news and
it feels like an unusual event actually
earthquakes are extremely common so this
is a map that I that I made last night
so this is a view of the iris seismic
monitor you can google that if you ever
want to see the map of where recent
earthquakes can happen or have happened
so all of the circles so the little pink
dots show all of the earthquakes that
that we know about that have happened in
the in the catalog the historical
catalog going back to about the 1970s
and then all of the circles these are
earthquakes of magnitude 4 or bigger
that have happened just in the last two
weeks amazing right so there's you know
hundreds of dots on this map and what
this map tells us is that earthquakes
are happening all the time and we you
know we hear about them really only when
they damage human infrastructure or they
have human you know human casualties but
the bottom line is that there are
earthquakes happening all the time so
you know when you have a few earthquakes
that sort of make the news right in a
row that's that's not unusual okay the
earth is sort of doing this all the time
and this is
is how the earth works the other thing
that you'll notice is that these
earthquakes are not distributed evenly
on the surface of the earth right they
seem to happen mostly in sort of lines
that are outlining the boundaries of
tectonic plates and I'm going to come
back to that question in a minute one of
the things here this is just a quick
list of what we'll talk about one of the
things I want to talk about in this talk
is not just talking about the phenomenon
that we see with earthquakes and
volcanoes but also talking about the why
why does what what about how the how the
earthworks gives us these earthquake and
volcanic disasters so I'm going to talk
a little bit about the fuel for natural
disasters I'm going to talk about the
theory of plate tectonics because it
explains almost everything about
earthquakes and volcanoes and then we're
going to talk some details all right so
if you want to understand why
earthquakes and volcanoes happen why
plate tectonics happens you have to
begin at the beginning I really mean
this you have to go back to the
beginning of the earth in order to
understand why we have natural disasters
ok so this of course is not a photograph
we don't have any pictures of the earth
forming this is an artist's rendering of
what it might have looked like when the
earth was forming ok so way back 4.6
billion years ago the earth formed by
you had the the big solar nebula and all
the planets started to form and the way
the terrestrial planets formed is you
had chunks a rock that are slamming into
each other like this ok and what happens
when you have two chunks of rock that
are slamming into each other like this
they have a lot of kinetic energy
because they're moving very fast and
they have mass they slam into each other
they stop moving so now they have no
more kinetic energy so what happens to
that energy we know that energy has to
be conserved so what happens where does
that energy go anyone want to take a
guess shout it out I heard somebody say
it heat yes exactly all of that kinetic
energy is all of these these things are
smashing together all that kinetic
energy goes into heat ok so this is what
we call primordial heat this is heat
that is left over from the formation of
the planet and this
heat it is incredibly hot in the in the
Earth's interior this is the heat that
is ultimately the energy source for
natural disasters and so if you think
about how much heat is the earth giving
off the total heat output from the earth
is 46 terawatts that's forty six
trillion watts okay who has a 40 watt
light bulb in your house somewhere an
ordinary light bulb maybe about 40 watts
that's how much power it takes so this
is trillion a trillion times that
roughly okay so that's a lot of heat all
right some of it a lot of it is left
over from this primordial heat some of
it is actually generated in the planets
interior by radioactive elements that
are often also giving off heat and what
then the planet needs to do is over time
it's cooling off it's cooling off to
space and it needs to get rid of all
that heat so one thing i'll just say is
though even though 46 terawatt sounds
like a lot if you think about how much
energy how much power the earth is
getting from the Sun it's actually an
even bigger number it's about a hundred
and seventy thousand terawatts so if you
think about the fuel for disasters like
hurricanes and tornadoes sort of
meteorological disasters floods there's
actually a lot more energy available for
those disasters than for geologic
disaster so it's kind of interesting
just if you think about where the energy
source is for this so I've said that the
earth needs to give off its heat it
needs to get rid of its heat it's
cooling off to space and this is the way
it happens okay up top you'll see these
are two images this is a computer model
of how the earth gets rid of its heat
and what happens is you have a process
called convection who's ever seen a lava
lamp have you ever seen a lava lamp I
don't have one I need to get one so that
I can bring it to these these kinds of
talks I love a lamp this is where you
plug it in it heats stuff up at the
bottom and the hot stuff Rises and then
it cools off and then eventually it
sinks again this is called convection
hot stuff is going up cool stuff is
going down and that's exactly what is
happening in the Earth's mantle as the
earth gets rid of its heat over time so
this is just a
uter movie on the on the left you see
blue stuff this is where how cold stuff
goes down here this is yellow stuff hot
stuff goes up and the the earth is
convicting to get rid of its heat one
point I want to make though is that in
contrast to the lava lamp the Earth's
mantle is solid it's not a liquid this
is a really common misperception but the
the earth is made of rocks the Earth's
mantle is made of rocks and even though
they're solid they can flow you know
what's a material that can do that that
we're all kind of familiar with silly
putty who's played with silly putty yeah
we love silly putty so silly putty is an
example of a material it's just like the
Earth's mantle when I teach my natural
disasters class I bring it and I give it
out to my students okay even though it's
a solid if you pull on it it'll stretch
it'll flow if I leave it here and over
the course of the talk it'll kind of
spread out into a little puddle so the
Earth's mantle just like silly putty all
right remember that fact ok so the
mantle is convecting to get rid of its
heat and the surface expression of that
process of mantle convection is called
plate tectonics ok and this is that map
that I showed that shows the boundaries
of the Earth's plates this is what's
happening this is now instead of looking
at a map view this is now we're kind of
looking at a cross-section ok so as the
mantle is moving around its convecting
hot stuff is coming up cold stuff is
going down and then at the surface we
have plate tectonics and that's the
surface expression of this mantle
convection process alright so we have
rigid plates with their it's called the
lithosphere so this is the Earth's crust
and then the top part of the mantle as
well their rigid and they're moving
around ok and at the boundaries of the
plates we have different geometries so
one is called a subduction zone where
you have a plate that's sinking back
into the mantle these are these you know
the blue the cold stuff going down in
that movie this is how this this happens
at the surface where you have a plate
that's sinking down into the mantle we
also have spreading centers this is
where two plates are spreading apart two
plates are moving apart from each other
that and you're making new oceanic crust
at under the the ocean and then you can
also have what's known as a transform
boundary so there's one right up there
transform boundary this is where two
plates move side to side okay so three
types of plate boundaries convergent
this is where plates come together like
that subduction zone divergent this is
where the plates come apart and
transform this is where the plates go
past each other that's really if you
remember those things three types of
plate boundaries you are going to
understand what kinds of earthquakes and
what kinds of volcanoes happen we're on
the earth so that's kind of the key idea
in this talk alright so remember that
this is the same thing that was the
cartoon view now this is the map view ok
so again we've seen a version of this
map already this is showing the
boundaries of all the tectonic plates
all right where do we live we live in
Connecticut right where's Connecticut on
that map are we on a plate boundary no
we are right in the middle of the of the
North American plate okay so that means
that we don't have really large and
destructive earthquakes here we do
occasionally have small ones anyone
remember when there was the earthquake
sequence in Plainfield's Connecticut
about a year and a half ago magnitude
3.3 so not a huge one we occasionally
have earthquakes here but for the most
part we don't have big ones because
we're in the middle of a plate but there
are lots of places that are on a plate
boundary right so if you live in Seattle
for example or if you live in California
or if you live in southern Alaska you
are on a plate boundary then you need to
worry about what are the earthquake and
volcano hazards associated with that ok
so again in map view this is showing the
locations of the plates and a little bit
about how they move the Pacific plate is
the largest tectonic plate on earth it's
moving this way in kind of a you know
Northwest direction and again you have
convergent plate boundaries where two
plates come together and one will often
dive beneath the other in a subduction
zone you have divergent plates thank you
awesome now I have the laser I have the
power perfect ok so now so you have a
transfer boundary so Southern California
is an example of that the San Andreas
Fault where two plates are going past
each other and you have a divergent
boundary such as here this is the East
Pacific Rise this plate moves this way
this move this moves this way and you
make new oceanic crust in between okay
one more time I'm I'm repeating this
because I want you to remember transform
fault two plates go past each other this
is a subduction zone or a convergent
boundary the two plates come together
and then this is a spreading center or
divergent boundary two plates move apart
all right so coming back to how this
ties into earthquakes and volcanoes and
tsunamis the thing to remember is that
earthquakes and volcanoes not all of
them but almost all of them happen on
plate boundaries okay so if you live
near a plate boundary you need to
understand what are the earthquake and
volcano hazards and if you don't like us
here in Connecticut then you know for
the most part we don't need to lose
sleep over this okay so yes as I there
again we we can we do have some
earthquakes here in New England they are
not the biggest and most damaging ones I
don't lose sleep over this so you
shouldn't either okay so this is why
plate tectonics is important if you want
to understand disasters understanding
what kind of plate boundary you're on
tells us what events are likely in terms
of earthquakes and volcanoes and what
sort of events they're likely to be all
right okay plate tectonics so now let's
talk about earthquakes all right this is
what I do I'm a seismologist I study
earthquake Center a structure so what is
an earthquake what is happening in the
ground when you have an earthquake this
is how it works okay say you have a
fault here you have a very convenient
stone wall built across the salt you
have sheep here okay so you have one
plate here you have one plate here these
plates are moving right that's the
theory of plate tectonics it tells us
that the plates are moving around with
respect to each other on the Earth's
surface okay so you have in this example
this plate is moving like this this
plates moving like that you're the
plates are moving but right at the fault
you have two blocks of rock
together and they get stuck okay they're
stuck together there's friction you know
it's just like if you try to move your
refrigerator you know you try to the
fridge that's been sitting in your
kitchen for like 20 years and you're try
to move it you push on it you push on it
it's stuck there's friction right
there's friction between your fridge and
the ground eventually though the
far-field motion of the plates overcome
that friction and the rock breaks okay
and you get sudden motion along the
fault here and it breaks and that's an
earthquake ok you can demonstrate that
pretty simply I have a little I'm coming
around here I have a little
demonstration here ok so what I have is
I have a little wooden board that has
sandpaper on it so it has a lot of
friction there's a brick ok so I'm
representing another tectonic plate do I
look like a tectonic plate yes thank you
ok so I'm going to pull here I'm going
to hold this in place I'm going to pull
all right I'm the tectonic plate I'm
moving I'm moving I'm moving the brick
isn't moving brick isn't moving and then
you get an earthquake ok as soon as the
the motion of the tectonic plate
overcomes the friction between the two
blocks of rock you get an earthquake ok
so I'm going to pull another earthquake
another earthquake another earthquake ok
that's basically how it works alright
and again if you want to prove this to
yourself you can go to your kitchen and
try to move your fridge it's not going
to be easy ok so that's what an
earthquake is that's how an earthquake
happens alright so I've just said that
we have earthquakes on plate boundaries
turns out we get different types of
earthquakes on different types of plate
boundaries ok spreading centers in the
middle of a plate there the plates are
thin the plates are hot the plates are
weak we get wimpy little earthquakes
there nothing to worry about plus
they're under the bottom of the ocean
where nobody lives I don't know anybody
that lives on the bottom of the ocean to
you know okay spongebob all right you
got me spongebob needs to worry about
these all right we have strike-slip
faults where we're the to let me find
one here yes so the were the two plates
go past each other here we get
moderately strong earthquakes subduction
zones this is where you have a plate
that's thick it's cold it has very
I friction very high strength it's very
strong in compression like a lot of
materials are this is so it can resist
the motion of the plates in between the
earthquakes this is where you get the
big guys okay subduction zones are where
we have the biggest earthquakes all
right so let's take a little tour around
the globe and see in what places we can
expect what kinds of earthquakes so
again is a map of the western US all
right this is the San Andreas Fault this
is one of the really famous faults that
we have here in the US this is a
transform fault okay so it's in that
middle category where you can get
moderately large earthquakes but not the
biggest that we get ever on the earth
okay so that's something to keep in mind
so here you have the North American
plate that's moving like this Pacific
plates moving like this plates are
moving past each other and where that
you overcome that friction and the rock
breaks that's an earthquake so along
with San Andreas Fault this is a place
where we have to worry about earthquakes
and people who live in California spend
a lot of time and energy worrying about
this a lot of times we see this in the
movies who saw san andreas not the most
accurate scientific depiction okay it's
a fun movie but so in san andreas i
think there was what like a magnitude 10
earthquake or something okay first of
all that's bigger than earthquakes can
get but also that's not accurate because
the biggest earthquakes we would expect
to have in a subduction zone not in LA
where the rock lives and flies
helicopters around so there you go
alright so to just look at a few
examples of transform fault earthquakes
the Loma Prieta earthquake in 1989 this
is known as the World Series earthquake
is it took place during the World Series
and had to cancel or move a couple
baseball games this was a magnitude 6.9
earthquake so that you know again 6.9
that's pretty big but it's not as big as
they can get I'm going to show you some
pictures from some really big ones and
unfortunately there were some
significant casualties from this event
because there was a very you know famous
and very tragic collapse of a section of
section of elevated highway so when
these events happen they definitely
damage to our infrastructure another
more recent and very tragic event
example of a transform fall to what we
call strike-slip earthquake was the
January 2010 earthquake in Haiti Haiti
is located right here in the Caribbean
Sea which is a very complicated region
lots of earthquakes you have a
subduction zone over here in this part
of the Caribbean and then on the island
of Hispaniola in of Hispaniola you have
several of these transform faults that
run right through including this one is
the Unruh kia fault sorry this is the
yes the armor key 0 fault here this is
the Septon channel fault up here and
unfortunately right under the city of
port-au-prince which is a very densely
populated city on January 12th there was
a magnitude seven earthquake very
shallow caused a huge amount of damage
to poorly built infrastructure and this
was actually one of the the five
deadliest earthquakes in human history
the number of casualties is not well
known but it was very large now a
magnitude seven earthquake is not the
biggest kind of earthquake that we can
get right but if it happens right under
a big city that has infrastructure that
was not designed to withstand
earthquakes then that you can have a lot
you can have a lot of you know very
tragic outcomes there okay seismologist
sort of have a saying that earthquakes
don't kill people buildings kill people
and it's this is a really good
illustration of that there is a lot of
not very well built infrastructure and
that's sort of where you get very tragic
results ok so we've talked about
transform faults now we're going to talk
about the convert the big guys so these
are the convergent margins you have two
plates coming together there's actually
three types of convergent zones so you
can have ocean ocean where to oceanic
plates are coming together the Aleutian
Islands or an example of that you can
have ocean continent so South America
the Western margin of South American is
is an example of that this is the Nazca
plate it's abducting beneath South
America and then you have can have
continents continents collisions like
here in the Himalayas where India
into Eurasia here so all three of these
types of convergent margins can cause
very big earthquakes India the India
Eurasia collision is a very nice example
you have the Indian land mass has moved
to the north over about the last 70
million years or so and now it's
slamming into the main part of Eurasia
this is why the Himalayan mountains are
there and it's also a place where we can
unfortunately expect to have very big
earthquakes and we saw that again
recently okay over the past you know
decade or 15 years or so there have been
major earthquakes in India Pakistan and
then a little over a year ago in Nepal
where there was an earthquake here or
this is a describing the 2001 but we we
remember just a little over a year and a
half ago the 2015 magnitude 7.8
earthquake in Nepal this this caused a
lot of damage in Katmandu it triggered a
landslide on Mount Everest again a lot
of you know we expect to have earthquake
hazards in this region but unfortunately
this is a region that has had very rapid
population growth and building codes you
know are either week or they're not
enforced well so it's a place where
there's large population an
infrastructure that is often not built
with the goal of withstanding an
earthquake in mind and again this is a
place where we can sort of use our
knowledge of plate tectonics to maybe
you know mitigate the hazard a little
bit we know here that we should you know
we should build buildings that can
withstand an earthquake all right the
largest earthquakes on the planet not
san andreas some like what The Rock will
tell you but they are at what we call
ocean subduction zone so here you have
an oceanic plate and then you have a
continent over here you have volcanoes
we're going to talk about that in a
second but you also get very large very
devastating earthquakes these are the
big guys okay these are your magnitude
99.2 even up to 9.5 which is the largest
earthquake that has ever been recorded
by by seismic instruments so there's
this is just a list of some very notable
ones the very
the recent magnitude 9 at this point was
five years ago was the 2001 earthquake
in Japan that of course you know got a
lot of attention and again these are the
big guys so where are these big
subduction zones where are the places
where we have to worry about this this
is mostly along the Ring of Fire so
there's a ring of subduction systems all
around the Pacific there are also other
ones I showed the example of Italy
that's a subduction zone there's here we
have one in the in the Caribbean but in
the for the most part it's around this
ring of fire so these are the places
that need to worry or really i don't
mean worry i need prepare for a
magnitude nine earthquake okay and
you'll notice that here in the US we
have several places that fall into this
category so here this is the Pacific
Northwest the Juan de Fuca plate is
subducting beneath North America so
cities like Seattle and Portland
Vancouver are exposed to that hazard and
then here in Alaska we also have a have
a subduction zone an Associated hazard
that is associated with these very large
earthquakes that happen at an oceanic
subduction zone is a tsunami okay this
is a little cartoon of how a tsunami is
generated I'll play this a couple times
you have here's your your plate going
down whoa this is fast there is the
earthquake and what happens is you have
the earthquake and it displaces the
water column and you get a tsunami so
then the tsunami waves spread apart from
the place where there was the earthquake
and they spread across the ocean basin
okay I'm going to play this one more
time I think I'm going to play this one
more time there we go alright so here's
the plate going down this is locked and
then all of a sudden you're going to
have the earthquake there it goes this
top plate pops up and it displaces a
whole bunch of water okay and then that
causes the tsunami all right this is
another thing that was inaccurate about
san andreas the movie to use those of
you who saw i remember how there was a
huge tsunami yeah okay so tsunamis in
order to trigger tsunami you need that
top plate in that cartoon to pop up you
need vertical displacement of a column
of water okay san andreas is what type
of a plate
Henry transform the plates are going
like this okay with this kind of
earthquake do you think you're going to
displace any water up no san andreas
thumb down on the science all right so a
few examples of famous tsunamis so there
was a very devastating tsunami in Alaska
and 1946 there are very sort of dramatic
pictures here's here's a lighthouse
before the tsunami this is the
lighthouse after the tsunami so this one
was was very destructive and this
tsunami actually caused destruction here
in in Alaska but then the wave traveled
all the way across the Pacific Ocean
basin and there was damages is another
very dramatic photo damage and people
unfortunately lost their lives in Hilo
Hawaii and after this this event and
then the the chile earthquake in 1960
this is the largest earthquake ever
recorded by seismometers so this is a
magnitude 9.5 subduction earthquake this
is about as big as they get this also
triggered a tsunami the tsunami
continued all the way to Japan all the
way across the Pacific Ocean basin and
there were fatalities in Japan so these
kinds of events really triggered a lot
of people to worry about well how can we
have a tsunami warning system okay
because the tsunami wave takes a pretty
long time to propagate across an ocean
basin and so in response to these events
there was they set up the Pacific
Tsunami Warning Center which is now
responsible for issuing tsunami warning
so that if there's an earthquake in say
chill a people in Hawaii will be warned
and they can evacuate and they can get
to higher ground so that was a good
result that came out of some of these
pacific ocean basins unfortunately there
was not a similar effort in the indian
ocean just set up a tsunami warning
system and in 2004 there was a very
devastating magnitude 9 i think is about
a magnitude 9.2 yeah it ranges a little
bit well sighs well i'll just argue a
little bit of over exactly what was the
magnitude of this earthquake for some
sort of complicated technical reasons
but this was a massive earthquake over a
magnitude nine caused a huge amount of
damage very close to the to the
epicenter but it also triggered a major
tsunami there was 20 meters of uplift on
the seafloor it displaced a huge amount
of the water column and it triggered a
tsunami that traveled across the Indian
Ocean basin this is a scientific model
of that tsunami so the earthquake
ruptured actually the fault that this
ruptured was enormous it ruptured a huge
portion of the subduction zone here over
a thousand kilometers triggered this the
tsunami wave that traveled across the
Indian Ocean basin it hit here in in
Thailand it hit certainly here in
Indonesia it hit a lot of the coast of
India Sri Lanka and actually it's there
were there were casualties due to this
as far away as Africa Kenda Kenya and
Tanzania and what's very frustrating to
me as a scientist is that there was no
tsunami warning system in place and and
we you know have the scientific
knowledge to predict that when you have
a magnitude nine subduction zone
earthquake like this there is very
likely to be a tsunami the tsunami wave
took hours to get to places like India
and Sri Lanka you know very close to the
to the earthquake epicenter it's hard to
issue a warning because the tsunami
happens very soon after the earthquake
but far away that's not the case and so
it's very frustrating to me that there
was not in place a tsunami warning
system at the time in the Indian Ocean
because that could have saved many lives
it's another example of how we can use
the knowledge that we have by
understanding plate tectonics and
understanding what kind of earthquakes
we might have in what different region
of a way that we can mitigate the hazard
from natural disasters so you probably
you know may have remembered seeing some
of these very terrible and dramatic
pictures of the tsunami waves on the on
the news so again just to wrap up on
earthquakes the real bad ones the
magnitude nines that trigger the
tsunamis and cause a lot of damage
subduction zones convergent margins
where you have two plates coming
together okay and luckily hearing
necticut we're far away from a plate
boundary all right next up volcanoes
who's excited for volcanoes yeah we all
are all right so I'm going to come back
to this map you've seen this map several
times before okay all the yellow dots
are the earthquakes all the little red
triangles are the volcanoes and what do
we notice what's the relationship
between volcanoes and plate boundaries
that's where they happen right so almost
all ninety percent of the volcanoes
happen on the plate boundaries but there
are some exceptions right what's our
famous exception that we kind of might
Hawaii yes that's the most famous one of
all so here's Hawaii Hawaii is right
here in the middle of the Pacific plate
okay where's the nearest plate boundary
I don't even know probably over here
this is many thousands of kilometers
away so we're going to talk about Hawaii
and why we have volcanoes there in a
second all right so what is a volcano
what is happening in the earth when you
have a volcano all right the idea is
that somehow you have melting of mantle
rocks remember I told you the mantle is
the solid it is not a liquid there is
not a vast ocean of liquid magma
everywhere in the mantle okay it
actually takes some doing to take a
mantle Rock and melt it okay and in fact
let's do a very quick little primer on
the physics of how you melt a rock okay
there are three ways to melt a mantle
Rock all right what if what is the way
if you want to if you want to melt
something say you're baking cookies you
have a stick of butter you need to melt
it what do you do to melt it you can
shout it out you hit it exactly you heat
it on the stove you put it in the
microwave you heat it okay that is not
how mantle rocks melt for the most part
okay it's actually really rare to have
melting in the earth due to heating okay
interesting right what's another way to
melt something all right say it's um
it's a cold winter day we just had this
like massive nasty ice storm your
driveway is a mess what do you do you
put salt on it exactly so another way to
melt things is to sort of add impurities
to it and that's going to change the
melting temperature of the material okay
so in the earth one of the things that
we quell the earth
beds is actually a little bit of water
you add a little bit of water to a rock
you lower the melting temperature and
you can melt it okay what's a third way
of melting something this one's maybe a
little less obvious because I not a
really great like real world example all
right think of you have a very earth a
rock deep in the earth it's under really
high pressure it turns out if I bring
that rock up to the Earth's surface and
the pressure goes down you can get
what's called decompression melting so
if you change the pressure and then the
rocks has the same amount of sort of
heat and energy it will melt if you
bring it up to a lower pressure okay so
you can heat it you can add impurities
or you can change the pressure those are
the three ways to melt a rock and
heating it that is usually not how they
how the earth works okay now you know
everything about mantle melting so now
we can talk about volcanoes all right so
we get volcanoes in a couple of
different places one is this mid-ocean
ridge okay so this is a divergent plate
boundary you have one plate moving this
way one plate moving this way as the
plates move apart you have you have
rocks that come up to sort of replace
the stuff that's moving away so right
underneath the ridge you have rising
rocks and as you change the pressure
they melt and they cause volcanoes okay
this is the this is a movie this is
really cool okay this is a movie of
mid-ocean ridge volcanism okay these are
called pillow basalts so this movie was
captured by a you know a ship that has a
has an ROV that can go down to the take
people down to the to the bottom of the
sea like spongebob okay so this is
pillow basalt so what happens is you
have this sort of runny magma that comes
out onto the Earth's onto the surface
onto the bottom of the sea floor it hits
the cold water and it cools it freezes
okay so you get this kind of neat really
neat like pillow like structure okay the
magma comes out it cools and you get
these pillows all right anyone want to
see an actual pillow basalt lava you
don't have to go to the bottom of the
sea to do it all you have to do is go to
the target in
meriden okay I'm not making this up go
behind the target and there's a there's
like kind of an exposed cliff it you can
see frozen pillow basalts that formed
during the breakup of Pangaea 200
million years ago right here in
Connecticut okay so you do not have to
be spongebob to actually see this target
in meriden okay all right so an
important thing about the lavas you guys
are all going to go to target just after
noon now I should be getting or I should
be getting paid for this all right so an
important thing about the lavas that you
have under the sea floor is that they're
pretty runny okay so it's like the lavas
that you get under the sea floor that
are made by melting the mantle Rock
right beneath the ridge okay it's kind
of like this is karo syrup okay it's
kind of like this so I'm going to pour
this into the into a bowl okay it's
runny it's gooey all right this is that
this is the kind of the consistency I
mean of course it's hotter you know it's
hotter like this than this this is not a
perfect analogy you have kind of this
gooey runny lava okay and we have this
under the sea floor and these pillow
basalt lavas and then we also have these
in places like Hawaii I promise to tell
you about Hawaii here it is Hawaii is
what's known as a hotspot okay and you
have hot you do have some hot hot
material scientists argue a lot over
this whether or not it comes all the way
from the core-mantle boundary or whether
it's shallower the most scientists
including myself think that it probably
comes all the way from the core-mantle
boundary it's a little hotter than the
mantle around it so it comes up and then
it but it's not molten so in them in the
bottom part of the mantle it's not
holdin but it's as it comes up it's
changing its pressure you get this deep
you know decompression depressurization
melting you get melting and then as the
plate moves over the hot spot you get a
series of volcanoes okay so here this is
Hawaii so here's the big island of
hawaii i was there with my natural
disasters class this past March it's
awesome and then going away you have
this line of islands that get
progressively all
her as the plate has moved over this hot
spot all right and in Hawaii the kind of
volcanism that you get the kind of lava
that you get is this runny you know it
pours easily it's this runny magma it
makes these basalt rocks and you can get
if you hit it on the right day you can
actually go and if you get the right
permits to don't actually do this get a
guy just get a guide to take you if you
ever go all right people get stupid and
go on the law of addition but if you are
at range geophysicist like my colleague
Dave Burke of eg who teaches in the
geology department you can actually go
up to this runny lava you can take a
little sample of it this is what what
Dave did he poked a stick in the lava
and you can get your very own basaltic
Rock okay but the point is is that this
kind of volcano it's not that dangerous
you can kind of you know you can kind of
walk up to the lava it's runny it's
flowing you know if it gets too close
you can walk away from it okay so this
this kind of thing it's very it
certainly can damage infrastructure so
this is a lava flow that is slowly
eating this road this is a bunch of Yale
students that are hiking on the lava but
this this kind of this kind of volcano
tends to not have fatalities right
because people can evacuate all right
Hawaii is a good example and get these
really dramatic like fountains of lava
you get these rivers of lava again it's
just like the Karo syrup example and
oftentimes it does damage infrastructure
so back in 2014 there was you know an
excursion of the lava into places where
people had built their homes but the
people were able to evacuate ok so these
tend to not be that dangerous this is
another example this is Iceland I feio
yokel I practiced that last night the
name of the volcano this is another
example of a volcano that sort of
erupted with this runny lava this
particular example actually also had a
steam explosion so again people were
able to evacuate but this steam
explosion put a lot of ash up into the
atmosphere and a lot of planes actually
were grounded because jet engines can't
fly through ash turns out okay we also
have some of these hotspot volcanoes
here in the US Yellowstone is a great
example this is not right on a plate
boundary Yellowstone has a very you know
kind of complicated history of eruption
they actually have had in the in the
geologic past about 600,000 years ago
these super eruptions so this is
potentially a hazard for the western US
but it does not erupt very often I mean
of course there are small eruptions like
The Geysers Old Faithful is there with
the catastrophic eruptions and these
hotspot regions are not very common ok
so now we're going to talk about
subduction zones so just like with
earthquakes remember we said earthquakes
the big guys the magnitude 9 those are
in subduction zones it's true for /
volcanoes too okay so the idea is you
have the plate going down like this the
plate has water in it so it's been
sitting on on the the bottom of the sea
floor for a long time it's now has a
bunch of minerals that have water in
their crystal structure locked into them
those rocks get down the water gets
cooked out of them you put water into
these rocks right here in the in the
wedge remember how you throw salt on
your driveway and it melts you put water
into these mantle rocks and they melt
and then you get volcanoes okay but at a
subduction zone that magma has to travel
up through this overriding continental
plate and what happens is that it's
melts some of the material around it and
you get a melt that's very different
than the basaltic magma that you get
under you know the pillow basalts under
the ocean here you get what's called a
silica rich magma okay remember how I
said the basalt magma was like the Karo
syrup all right the silica rich magma is
more like this that what is this pizza
dough okay anyone hungry for pizza now I
am and go get pizza for lunch okay if
the if the basalt runny magma is the
Karo syrup this is the magma that you
make at these at these volcanoes in a
subduction zone okay it's thick it's
pasty it is not running you imagine this
lump of pizza dough coming out of
volcano it's going to get stuck it's
going to it's not going to want to just
run smooth
Lee and instead what happens is the
magma gets stuck in the volcano and it
builds up pressure if you get water you
get volatile and you have an explosive
eruption because this magma can't flow
nicely like the basaltic magma okay so
because of this this is why we get the
big catastrophic volcanic eruptions
alright so this is basically what i just
said they're richer and silica they're
thicker and pasty they plug up the
volcano's just like pizza dough okay so
this is why you get catastrophic
eruptions okay because you have this
pasty stuff it's full of water right I
just said that the way you make this is
you put water into mantle rocks okay so
you have this pasty stuff it plugs up
your building up water you're building
up water and it's very much like if you
take a bottle of soda you shake it up
what would happen if i were to unlit
what do you think would happen shout it
out what's going to happen alright
should i do it do you Jeremy do you
triple dog dare me alright for science
I'm doing it I'm gonna make sure i'm
away from the electronics day the things
we go for science
okay so that is what happens when you
have a giant volcano at a subduction
zone okay would you want to be there
when that giant volcano explodes it a
Seductor no I would not okay these are
examples of famous where they're called
stratovolcanoes in subduction zones this
is where you get these explosive
eruptions I want to leave time for
questions so I'm not going to go through
this in detail but i'm gay i'm going to
show some cool pictures and so it shows
some cool examples okay this is what's
known as a plenty interruption named for
Pliny the Younger the example so he
witnessed the eruption of Vesuvius in
the Year 79 this is what these look like
okay the thick pasty magma plugs up the
volcano you build up this pressure you
build up all this water and steam and
ash and then eventually you get this
giant explosion okay so you get this
explicit big ash cloud that goes up into
the atmosphere and unfortunately what
can happen is that you get this big ash
cloud it goes up into the atmosphere it
cooled off a tiny bit and then you get a
collapse the whole hot ash cloud
collapses down the side of the volcano
this is known as a pyroclastic flow this
is a very scary picture of this is the
eruption of mount pinatubo in the
philippines in 1991 this truck trying to
race away from this pyroclastic flow
cloud this is where the hazards come
from with these kinds of volcanoes okay
with the city of Pompeii was destroyed
by this kind of pyroclastic flow you
know back in the year as the Year 79
tambora another volcano in Indonesia
another famous example of this closer to
home here in the US this is the
Caribbean we have a series of volcanoes
here this is a subduction zone
subduction zones are where the action
happens a very famous example of this
mount Pele in Martinique it had a
catastrophic eruption in 1902 there was
a direct blast
ira plastic flow that came down the
mountain destroyed the city of mount
Pele and there were two survivors in the
whole city okay almost everyone everyone
died there's kind of a tragic backstory
about how the governor prevented
everybody from evacuating so kind of
demonstrates that you need to have good
disaster management all right this is
mount Pele today this is what it looks
like I took this picture because we took
a natural disasters field trip you can
hike to the top it's beautiful the
Caribbean I mentioned the Caribbean
partly because it's fairly close to us
but it really is a big Center for first
sort of volcano hazards this is the
island of Dominica beautiful place very
small island I think it's about the size
of the island of Martha's Vineyard here
in New England it has nine active
volcanoes and it has a population of
people that live roseau here is the big
city that live right surrounded by a
ring of these volcanoes this is a
subduction zone these have the potential
to have a very catastrophic eruption so
again we're using plate tectonics to
understand what kind of volcanic hazard
people in Dominica need to plan for
another neat thing that you see there is
you have a lot of these steam eruptions
volcanoes and you can go to what is
known as the boiling lake it's called
the boiling lake because it is a boiling
Lake the lake is actually boiling it is
extremely cool you can kind of see I
took these pictures they're not that
great but this is just another kind of
example of how the volcano all the teeth
from the the volcanic rocks at depth
kind of come up this is just a
gratuitous beautiful picture of the cal
buco volcano in chile and then also
mount st. helens i know some of us in
the room some of you in the room
actually not me remember the Mount st.
Helens I was to remember the mount st.
Helens eruption that was a good example
here in the continental US of this kind
of catastrophic volcanic eruption
alright I'm going to summarize and then
I'll take a couple questions geologic
disasters due to play tectonics the
reason that this happens is the earth is
cooling to space okay the earth is
getting rid of its heat by convection
that's why we have plate tectonics
that's why we have or
quake and volcanoes and tsunami
disasters okay if you understand plate
tectonics and you understand what type
of earthquake and what type of volcano
you might get in a different place and
why that goes a long way towards
planning for natural disasters okay and
the big bad guy here is really
subduction zones okay subduction zones
where one plate is diving under another
this is where you get the big
earthquakes this is where you get the
catastrophic volcanoes so in terms of
thinking about hazards that's that's the
bad guy that we have to plan for and
I'll just end on a positive note okay
because i know there's sort of a lot
anytime you talk about natural disasters
it's kind of a lot of you know death and
destruction and dramatic pictures but
but I'm hopeful ok I'm going to end on a
positive note because I am an optimist
about this if we understand and plan for
disasters we can mitigate a lot of their
hazard and that's why the scientists
like me who study plate tectonics and
who study the Earth's interior that's
why we do what we do because it's going
to help us to mitigate and plan for
these disasters they don't do as much
damage to human life and infrastructure
I'll stop there you guys have been a
great audience thank you very much
thank you questions I know if you have
to leave no problem I know I talked it
until noon I couldn't help myself all
right if we have questions you got to be
a little quiet back in here okay thank
you yes you have asked you should be a
geophysicist because you have just asked
a fundamental question that we do not
know the answer to and that a lot of
people including me are trying to study
so we don't really know so so that I
mean the theory so that I mean the
reason that some sometimes you have hot
upwellings right is because of
connection okay so so you're always
going to have some hot stuff coming up
as the earth as a mantle convection gets
rid of its heat why they seem to stay in
place for a long time that is not a quiz
a great question that we don't
understand and why you know why do they
form where they do if they're really
coming from the core-mantle boundary why
do they form where they do and there are
a bunch of hypotheses but this is
actually a question that I actively
research and a lot of geophysicists do
so you should become a geophysicist yeah
all right back there oh my gosh okay
well here's the thing if you want yeah
okay exactly natural disasters gng 100
yeah so if you want it you see lava
today you have to go to a place like
Hawaii or Iceland but this is cool if
you want to see rocks that are lava that
has cooled off lava from a volcano that
have cooled from long ago you can go up
to east rock in new haven or west rock
or you can go up to sleeping giant and
these are pleased our rocks that are
made these were volcanoes not the big
explosive kind but the kind of runny
basalt kind okay so if you want to go
get your own volcanic rock this
afternoon you can go to sleeping down
I in or east rock and you can pick up a
lava rock there but it was it was a
volcano a long time ago but still it's
not bad yeah um good question i do not
know very much and you mean Yosemite or
Yellowstone Yellowstone okay i was going
to say i do not know what about you
somebody so it is it is one of these
what the term is a super caldera there's
a another one in toba in the in
indonesia it is again not well known why
you get these enormous they're called
super super caldera explosions in some
regions and not in others but we
actually know pretty well that about
600,000 years ago there was a massive I
to forget exactly the size of the
caldera but it's huge and then there was
the ash fall from that super caldera
eruption covered much of the continental
United States so these eruptions are
potentially massive again they're rare
so please don't lose sleep over this but
you know it's the kind of thing that
that in the in the geologic past you
know there were some some things some
things that happened that would really
affect human life and infrastructure if
they happened again today yeah yes why
are there different that's a great
question there you get different kinds
of lava because rocks melt under
different circumstances okay so under a
mid-ocean ridge the rocks come up the
pressure is low and they melt and that's
it so that it makes the runny lava under
a subduction zone the rocks are melting
and they're melting all of that silica
rich continental crust above them the
silica chains their little Anna if you
think of what what the molecules what
the atoms look like they make these
little almost like pyramids tetrahedra
and then they stick together in these
long chains and those chains of silica
molecules that get into the lava is what
makes it like this okay it's like the
chains of molecules make it sticky and
and running and you don't have those
silica chains in the in the the
mid-ocean ridge Magnus that's an
excellent question
if you want to come and take
geochemistry sometime you'll learn all
the details one last one yes yes so so I
want to make a little bit of a
distinction between prediction I didn't
talk about this at all prediction is a
word that people like me kind of hate
all right because we give particularly
earthquakes we cannot predict
earthquakes so we cannot we can we can
make forecasts and say okay there's a
you know fifty percent of chance of this
happening over the next decade or
whatever we can't predict earthquakes I
my own opinion is we will never be able
to predict earthquakes that's my that's
my opinion but what we can do for
tsunamis is when when an earthquake
happens we know it pretty quickly
because we have seismometers all over
the globe we can use that data in real
time is to sit to determine oh there was
a magnitude nine earthquake and then you
can warn people you know you can you
know pick up the phone or of course net
it's all automated and by computers but
you can warn you know say if there's an
earthquake in chile you can warn hawaii
and then and say in five hours there's
going to be a tsunami so they set off
you know they set off the sirens
everybody knows to evacuate the key is
that you have to have the infrastructure
in place to do that warning and i think
it's really important that you know we
invest we as sort of taxpayers invest in
that infrastructure because it saves
lives thank you